Madagascar is known for its rich
biodiversity but it is one of the
poorest countries in the world with
abysmal health conditions maternal and
child mortality are off the charts half
of all children are malnourished and per
capita spending on health is the lowest
in the world
this is science writer Leslie Roberts
who with support from the Pulitzer
Center traveled to Madagascar to report
on a comprehensive effort to tackle the
country's health crisis well I've been
to a lot of places and Madagascar was
different in a way because of the sheer
beauty you're going down the road past
poor villages but you with a spectacular
landscape but when you get out to the
villages there's absolutely no health
care at all an eclectic group of
scientists has founded a nonprofit
called pivot they are working in a
remote district in southeastern
Madagascar the cofounders are convinced
that the piecemeal approaches that
attract most donor funding such as bed
nets for malaria or treatment for HIV
simply aren't enough in a place that's
broken they say you have to tackle the
entire health system the first thing
pivot did was say if you want us to be
here let's build a health post together
so pivot supplies all the building
materials and the community builds the
health post and they inaugurate them
with the ceremony so when we went to
visit we toured the clinic and such
children being tested for malnutrition
the founders looked over the ledgers
where they record every patient they see
and what's wrong with them and then the
villagers came out with their box
guitars and traditional music and put on
this wonderful performance
[Music]
their approaches to address the entire
health system everything from getting in
the best obstetricians because maternal
mortality is a big problem to having
paper clips in the clinic sometimes
nobody would file their drug orders on
time because the printer had broken so
they fix printers they put in latrines
they pay the pharmacists they bring in
solar panels and then they're also doing
intensive training of healthcare workers
what set spivot apart is their almost
obsessive focus on data their goal is
not only to fix a broken health system
and save lives in this district but to
collect enough data to show what works
in global health and fix what does it
they collect data from every single one
of these health posts where they do
record any drug dispensed any patient
seen anyone referred and then the same
thing the next level up the health
clinics themselves the health centers
that serve more people and they follow
every child treated what the outcome is
do they recover do they not the
challenges are huge
perhaps the biggest is simply the
terrain that's gorgeous landscape that
gave rise to all these different species
keeps people isolated in villages and
many of them are five ten 15 kilometres
even from a road much thus the clinic
and if you're sick you really can't
navigate a footpath like that so people
get make stretchers out of branches and
sheets and carry people to a clinic
which it sometimes can take days
pivot is trying all sorts of strategies
to bring healthcare to the population
training community health workers in the
villages overhauling the crumbling
clinics in one hospital and they created
an ambulance system available 24/7 the
thing that led to most improvements as
they reduced all the user fees before
pivot got there the health centers were
so bad that if they actually walked all
the way there they might be closed there
might be no doctor and they saw in their
first two years dramatic declines in
child mortality and maternal mortality
the number of people just going to a
clinic increased data show almost all
the gains so far occurred in people who
live within five kilometers of a health
clinic they've decided to really shore
up the health care in the villages and
they have a pilot project that they're
just starting now to try paying health
workers and at the same time they are
scaling up so far their pilot project
has reached about 95 thousand people
they want to reach all 200,000 in the
district by 2020 and if their model
works they want to expand to the rest of
the country which means there are 24
million more people to go
[Music]